[Musique]
on doit apprendre la beauté par le son
et je dis bien par le sont par le bruit
le bruit ce n'est pas quelque chose
d'incongru le bruit c'est la vie c'est
le fondement même on vient recueillir le
dernier souffle et après quand il ya
plus de souffle il ya plus rien à la
naissance il ya le cri et avant le cri
n'y avait rien d'accord donc le bruit
c'est le signe de la vie et c'est beau
c'est fondamentalement beau
[Applaudissements]
notre environnement sonore nous offre
parfois le meilleur mais aussi souvent
le pin
[Musique]
ouais
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous allez à vue
non je ne chante pas
mais depuis quelques années ce n'est
plus une fatalité un nouveau métier
n'est designer sonore
pour moi le design sonore c'est
premièrement penser les sons à partir du
moment où on a pensé des sons a déjà
fait un grand pas c'est rare c'est
toujours difficile de donner une
définition du design sonore puisque on a
peut-être plusieurs évidemment qu'une
seule mais j'aurais envie de dire que le
design sonore c'est donc inventé les
sons émanant d'un objet ou d'un espace
dans un environnement de manière à ce
que la fonction soit mise en avant la
signature de l'objet soit mise en oeuvre
également qu' une certaine osmose entre
l'objet et puis son utilisateur une
ergonomie facilité peut-être grâce aux
sons et de travail et ses sonorités de
manière à ce qu'elle soit quelque chose
qui paraissent presque instinctivement
normal sortant de cet objet son qui sort
la voix de l'objet en quelque sorte
qui pense laissons les acousticiens et
les psycho cousty siens des
scientifiques qui étudie et analyse nos
perceptions auditives en tenant compte
de notre mémoire collective des sens
[Musique]
puis des designers sonores et des
compositeurs qui réinvente écrivent de
nouveaux sons pour nos objets et nos
espaces publics
le but étant de donner du sens aux sons
et de l'émotion à 6
[Musique]
achèteriez vous aujourd'hui une voiture
qui qui qui n'auraient pas un beau
l'industrie automobile a été la première
à prendre conscience de l'importance des
sons est allé travailler pour vous
informer vous rassurer vous séduire et
aussi faire rugir de plaisir notre
virilité à nous les hommes
alors là on est en 4e par exemple à 80
km/heure donc on pourrait imaginer qu'on
est sur le périphérique parisien
donc on pourrait enlever du bruit
aérodynamique par exemple voilà vous
voyez qu'on est tout de suite dans une
ambiance sonore beaucoup plus calme le
moteur est beaucoup plus présent cela
dit le son de ce moteur il est pas bon
par rapport aux résultats qu'on a
obtenus lors de tests clients on peut
pas dire qu'il ait une coloration très
particulière en tout cas il a peu de
coloration très jolie pas tellement typé
sport est ce qu'on pourrait rechercher
pour ce type de véhicule c'est une
coloration à peu un peu roucoulante et
ceci pourrait être atteint par exemple
en opérant ce genre de modification
nantes avec le son est tout de suite
beaucoup plus haut
plus plus un peu plus agressif plus
chantant une coloration plus original
plus exotique que ce qu'on attendait
juste avant
le principal intérêt cet outil c'est de
pouvoir vraiment design et le son du
moteur pour atteindre tel ou tel type h
sonore de la même façon que l'on
pourrait transformer une guitare en
trompette presque en jouant sur les
harmoniques on peut transformer une
voiture type est plutôt grave confort
basses fréquences cocon en une voiture
beaucoup plus aigus métallique même
parfois criardes même si ce n'est pas
toujours ce qu'on recherche pour aller
vers des types âge plus sportif
attachez vos ceintures et des niveaux
faire fermer votre portière
à bord les fonctions visuelles et
sonores se multiplient alors pour éviter
les confusions les spécialistes invente
des sons informatif et agréable bien sûr
par exemple pour le pour le clignotant
[Musique]
autre note autres timbres chang'e 2
n'est pas si simple
d'abord il faut respecter ce que le son
d'un clignotant nous évoque
inconsciemment à l'origine ce sont été
produit par le mécanisme lui même exit
cette mécanique tous les designers
sonores du monde avant aujourd'hui dès
qu'ils gardent cette cadence
de plus ces nouveaux sons de clignotants
renforce l'image que l'on veut donner du
véhicule
[Applaudissements]
outre-rhin certains constructeurs
automobiles travaillent le design sonore
de leurs modèles comme une vraie
partition musicale
[Musique]
des femmes pour les sont fonctionnels de
la fenêtre du siège
il est très important qu'ils aient la
même intensité qui soit en harmonie
c'est capital car cela renforce la
notion de valeur de la voiture
premier contact avec le véhicule
la portière hors de question qu'elle ne
soit pas à la hauteur de vos attentes
c'est tout un art pour que le sun juste
à l'ouverture et à la fermeture des
portières on doit avoir aucun phénomène
parasites
il ne faut pas que l'on entende la vitre
vibrer ni aucun bruit d'acier leçon doit
être assez grave ce qui va souligner
l'aspect sécuritaire de la voiture le
facteur déterminant ce sont les joints
il faut qu'ils soient réalisés dans une
matière très dense
c'est ce qui va nous permettre d'établir
le son caractéristique de la portière
aujourd'hui la technique permet de
nettoyer entièrement un moteur de tous
bruits parasites
il suffit ensuite de composer une
nouvelle symphonie en échappement majeur
de là à faire ronfler un petit moteur
pour vous donner l'illusion qu'il serait
plus puissant
e on les appelle les oreilles elle
traque et design le moindre sens pour
que votre véhicule sonne bien une équipe
qui travaille pendant des mois à ce
qu'on appelle la signature phonique du
vécu
[Musique]
à lausanne une marque connue pour son
célèbre s'est spécialisé dans les sons
qui croustille des glaces aux barres
chocolatées en passant par la mousse au
chocolat et les céréales plus à
croustiller meilleur c'est il paraît que
nos neurones adore être stimulé la sorte
du coup pas un 1 1 n'est laissé au
hasard pour preuve l'incroyable machine
qui l'ont inventé le krusty m laval ats
15 alpharma les matchs pour vérifier la
qualité d'un produit
nous avons inventé cette machine afin de
voir le son des céréales lorsqu'elles
sont écrasés l'appareil est tout simple
la machine va exercer une force
mécanique sur le produit limite les
dents lorsqu'elle marche
pour cela nous utilisons ce tampon on
n'y a fixé un microphone qui nous permet
d'enregistrer les sons de céréales mais
on peut également enregistrer les
vibrations sonores des os du crâne
provoquée par la mastication
le véritable enjeu pour les fabricants
que les céréales restent croustillantes
le plus longtemps possible dans le lait
une course contre la montre que chacun
essaie de gagner les résultats
informatique offre de précieuses
informations la matière mais rien
nouveau notre avis à nous consommateurs
léger croustillant plus moins pas assez
ces experts gouttes évalue écoute
s'exprime comme ils le peuvent car nous
disposons de peu de mots pour décrire
nos émotions sanaa assourdi 1,8 graines
sèches ou de pluie sèche à sombreffe
rebondissant sam bruit sec répété très
rapidement des frappes aux panélistes
sont pas habitués à noter à évaluer le
son et vocabulaire est beaucoup plus
pauvre que pour des termes de goût donc
ça se fasse faire par des références
c'est à dire elles vont penser à des
idées relatives à des sons que ça va
leur rappeler par exemple la pluie la
grêle et ensuite c'est à nous derrière
essayer de les orienter sur des termes
beaucoup plus scientifique et objectifs
et qui vont parler à tous puisque le but
c'est d'avoir un la fin un vocabulaire
commun qui soit compréhensible par tout
le monde et analysable par tous nos
matches c'est à dire assourdi c'est le
gros problème on sait pas parler des
sons parce qu'on sait parler d'écrire un
petit peu mou mais on
on rattache toujours à une source à
venir ça sonne métal où ça sonne carton
ça ça ceci cela toujours attaché à
quelque chose physiquement palpable
c'est aussi ça le son le son c'est c'est
quelque chose de l'immatériel
si le produit n'a pas un bon goût le son
ne peut pas être à l'heure et ne peut
pas masquer en fait c'est mauvais
produit donc ça vient comme un
supplément et en aucun cas comme quelque
chose qui cacherait un mauvais
fonctionnement ou un mauvais goût du
produit
alors comment faire pour que ça
croustille ils disent jouer sur le choix
des farines de certains ingrédients et
sur les techniques de fabrication
les mauvaises langues diront que c'est
l'excès de sucre qui permet de prolonger
la durée du croustillant
mais chut c'est un secret industriel
bien gardé mais quissac district où la
structure d'une céréale et cellulaire
elle est constituée de petites bulles
d'air et ce sont elles qui produisent le
sont mais personne ne s'imagine que même
une mousse au chocolat produit aussi ce
genre de son parce que vous ne l'avez
peut-être pas remarqué mais eux ils
l'ont fait exprès quand votre cuillère
rentrer dans la mousse au chocolat safer
historische historiquement à l'époque du
roi soleil les cuisines y organisait
déjà des compétitions à la cour c'était
l'occasion de se mesurer en créant des
plats dont les textures était très
différente faut nous voyait tout cela
n'est pas nouveau
deux sites être associé à ce fonds
[Musique]
d'abord entendu comme un bruit comme en
tapant entendu comme un bruit
comment mon ils font n'importe
quoi
dans cette agence de design on fabrique
du du du pour que le produit souvent de
luxe s'élève à la hauteur de la marque
et raconte son contenu si on prend un
bâton de rouge à lèvres on recherche
deux sont bien précis le premier c'est
le nom sont justement pas de son ce
qu'on recherche dans un mécanisme c'est
le glissement le frottement et là aussi
c'est la qualité même du bâton de rouge
à lèvres qu on sous-entend à travers la
gestuelle
donc là il n'y a pas de sous au moment
où leur ferme
la problématique est différente c'est la
sécurité
la sécurité c'est d'entendre un son qui
permet de dire la femme je suis sûr que
mon bâton de rouge à lèvres ne sourira
pas dans mon sac
toujours dans le domaine de la beauté
d'un boîtier de maquillage vous avez là
aussi s'il ya des parties internes les
mécanismes doit être absolument un
sonore
par contre même chose au moment où on
referme le boîtier on veut être sûr que
le boîtier bien fermé et d'entendre le
cliquetis tout ça est très difficile à
mettre au point sa demande des mois de
travail parce qu'une telle technologie
difficile c'est vrai qu'un boîtier comme
ça vous avez 18 pièces d'injection
différentes donc leçon participe
énormément de la perception de l'objet
et donc de la perception qu'ils aimaient
là qu'est née la marque
formes couleurs matières sont tout est
travaillé en même temps souvenez-vous du
flacon d'eau de cologne de votre enfance
et du son si particulier de son bouchon
quand vous entendez ce sont des vies
semant le bruit si vous voulez de la
deûle avec elite sur sur le verre est
immédiatement vous savez que vous êtes
dans le dans le monde des eaux fraîches
et des autres cologne donc c'est un
choix s'il voulait qu est un choix de
bouchage qui est un choix esthétique
aussi mais c'est aussi un choix qui
ramène si vous voulez à 7 à cette
mémoire
là on est sur un autre flacon où on a
tout à fait innover au niveau des
système de bouchage et qui ont donné
naissance à un nouveau son on a intégré
à l'intérieur du bouchage en injection
une pièce qui est un aimant on joue la
délicatesse la féminité donc ils se
retirent mais ne peut pas tomber on ne
travaille pas le son sur sur
informatique
heureusement que dans ce métier on on
touche on touille vont au modèle
hongrois en fait du bruit on s'exprime
jeudi avec les avec la avec la matière
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'histoire du jouet est aussi jalonnée
de son au 19e siècle les trains
faisaient et plus tard les joies
mécanique faisait
après on a eu des espèces de peau de
potes dans les jouets en caoutchouc des
années 50 puis les chances des comics
sont arrivés avec leur lot de le design
sonore fait ses premiers pas dans le
monde de l'enfance
ce n'est pas uniquement des sons qu'on
récupère à droite à gauche c'est à dire
qu'on fait appel à des spécialistes en
particulier pour cette nouvelle gamme un
spécialiste qui connaît bien l'univers
des petites en france et qui a déjà créé
un certain nombre de sons donc on a un
vrai travail de designers qui manipulent
les sons qu'au moins les pulls ray la
palette de couleurs ou manipuler des
formes a écrit donc en fait si on prend
des exemples le bébé il a 3 5 mois son
audition n'est pas parfaite sa vue n'est
pas parfait il commence à expérimenter
le monde qui l'entourent donkey à faire
une relation entre ce qu'ils voient ce
qui fait que sa main et des sons qu'il
entend j'ai un petit exemple on a mis au
point un hochet donc en fait un hochet
on le secoue
ça fait du bruit c'est depuis une
centaine d'années qu'on as simplement
ici voilà j'ai arrêté de secouer le son
s'est arrêtée tout qu'on fait
ge a fait un apprentissage que j'ai la
possibilité de créer quelque chose qui
s'y créent à un bruit qui n'existe pas
naturellement parce que je le veux je le
pousse et quand j'arrête j'ai le silence
donc il ya eu tout un travail réalisé
avec les designers ainsi pour tenir un
bruit entre les certaines billes de
plastique et le plastique qui est là et
puis aussi bien travaillé la forme pour
que les bills repose tout de suite au
fond quand il n'ya plus de mouvement
donc obtenir le silence
voilà un petit livre qui s'adresse aux
enfants qui ont plus de 12 mois
c'est la fin de l'histoire on essaye
d'endormir bébé de le calmer parce que
aussi les parents aimeraient bien dormir
la nuit
on a travaillé que designer pour avoir
un son qui est un peu aiguë un peu plus
hâtif et s'ils vont faire un
enregistrement le terrain du bruit de ce
qui se passe dans l'utérus
le bébé entend du bruit des artères et
des veines qui pulse c'est exactement ça
chiche c'est effectivement la fois un
bruit de respiration sifflante
mais justement on l'a fait sifflante
pour retrouver un peu ce bruit
fondamental je dirais que tout être
humain entendu une fois dans sa vie
le travail du son sur les jouets a une
importance capitale l'oreille d'un
enfant dès sa naissance à une
sensibilité extraordinaire
c'est le seul sens qui lui permet de se
projeter dans le monde qui l'entourent
un monde parfois cruel cette couveuse
par exemple n'est pas ce que l'on peut
appeler un havre de paix
les étudiants de l'école nationale
supérieure de création industrielle
saint savin se sont penchés sur la
question
les étudiants avaient constaté que les
couveuses utilisé aujourd'hui était
pratiquement des petites chambres de
torture pour les nouveau-nés et je
plaisante pas en disant jantes de
torture c'est que les nuisances sonores
sont considérables elles sont à
couvercle plat souvent en passant le
personnel pose des choses dessus ça
résonne à l'intérieur d'un chat l'équipe
de design travail à un concept de
couveuses qui bien évidemment va prendre
en charge toutes les contraintes donc là
vous pouvez voir le couvercle il est
d'une telle forme qu'on peut rien
imposer dessus une équipe acoustique
travail tout linthout l'intérieur pour
désolidariser toutes les parties qui
font qu'ils émettent du bruit de
l'ensemble de la coque
une fois que ce travail est fait on à
assurer le confort du prématuré on
ajoute la dimension de relations avec le
monde extérieur de haut parleurs ce sont
des fenêtres auditive
on diffuse des paysages sonores en
relation avec ce qui se passe de la
saison extérieure
donc ce sont des petits paysages sonores
et on y ajoute un système
d'enregistrement la famille papa maman
frère soeur vienne peuvent laisser un
message est régulièrement dans
l'habitacle il ya une présence de voix
humaine autres que celles qu'on peut
entendre du personnel ce projet a été
breveté les brevets coûte très cher mais
l'industriel qui l'a acheté pour le
compte de l'école saint sabin n'a jamais
fabriqué cette couveuse
dommage
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il sait se faire oublier
si on prend beaucoup d'objets
domestiques par exemple des appareils
électroménagers on s'aperçoit qu'il y en
a pas ils font tous un bruit pas
possible souvent c'est insupportable au
point qu'on on rechigne à les utiliser
pour ça typiquement un aspirateur qui
quand vous êtes en train de passer
l'aspirateur vous entendez pas le
téléphone sonner ou des choses comme ça
c'est extrêmement gênant
ce bruit de moteur quelque part on
pourrait le supprimer d'ailleurs je
pense qu'on a tous les moyens techniques
pour le faire la question n'est pas là
la question c'est une question de coût
et remplacé en fait ce bruit de moteur
par des bruits réellement signifiant
pour l'appareil par exemple ça pourrait
être
on passe l'aspirateur et on entend les
choses qui monte dans le tuyau et ça
fait des jolies cliquetis ou des choses
comme ça
[Musique]
c'est quand même incroyable que cet
appareil coller à notre oreille soit
aussi bruit messieurs les fabricants ne
pourriez vous pas faire quelque chose
pour nous on peut être cynique et dire
que le designer sonore a forcément un
avenir parce que on va bientôt avoir
fait le tour des moyens de plus value
par le chic visuel formelle couleurs etc
et donc quand même falloir continuer à
faire du profit qu'est ce qui va
permettre de faire du profit ça sera le
bon sont donc pas mon cas mon sens c'est
inéluctable
[Musique]
entendu comme un bruit entendu comme un
bruit
comment les lave vaisselle silencieux
pour ne pas se tromper un environnement
sonore chez soi bien équilibré
ça veut pas dire tous les objets qui
vont 1 sont au même niveau sonore c'est
simplement le pouvoir les mariés entre
eux de manière ce qui se complète qui
face à un univers sonore plutôt agréable
et pas des pics qui s'en vont et des
choses qu'on n'entend pas et qui agresse
enfin donc oui le sont ils et cette
matière invisible mais qui participent
complètement à la vie d'un individu
le packaging bénéficie aussi des apports
du design sonore
le son de l'objet nous rassure sur la
conservation du produit sur sa fraîcheur
il était une fois le le concept et le
concept d'une boîte type thermos ce qui
est intéressant c'est quand on ouvre la
boîte on entend le souffle de la
décompression au moment de l'ouverture
c'est très important pour le
consommateur qu'il sache que son produit
était préservée donc c'est aussi
important que la que la forme on aurait
pu la route par calage enfin par par
précision civile et on peut la rendre
totalement silencieuse et c'est vraiment
un choix et l'intérêt c'est que ce choix
confirme la technicité du produit c'est
pas simplement pour faire croire que
c'est une c'est une réalité
si on avait pu rendre encore plus de
souffle
bon ce n'était pas possible parce qu'on
est allés au maximum de ce qu'on pouvait
faire
on aurait été encore plus performant
dans le domaine des eaux minérales
cherche bien évidemment là la pureté la
transparence le but d'une eau minérale
c'est la plus pure possible la pureté
c'est ses leçons de ces notions de la
glace et le son de l'inscrit sur la
neige
cd sont assez assez sec très très frêle
est-ce que ça qu'on choisit ses
matériaux vous avez pour d'autres
produits qui sont plus d'ailleurs de
l'ordre des sirops par exemple donc ils
y ont une autre approche conceptuelle
des matériaux qui n'ont pas du tout le
même le même source ce sont des
matériaux plus plus grave même se sont
même si ce sont tous les deux des
matières plastiques la manière de
repenser complètement en fait un objet
parce par les sons qu'il aimait et du
coup de créer notre relation entre entre
l'utilisateur et l'objet c'est ce à quoi
s'attache les chercheurs du département
design sonore de l'ircam l'institut de
recherche et de coordination
acoustique/musique les industriels qui
font appel à l'équipe design sonore de
l'ircam appartiennent à les domaines
industriels relativement traditionnels
comme la l'automobile la téléphonie et
plus généralement des fabricants de
machines
les chercheurs ont donc mis au point des
outils scientifiques et informatiques
comme cette cartographie perceptible des
sons
une analyse précise qui répond aux
attentes de ses industriels donc une
étude qu'on a réalisé avec edf par
exemple concerne les convecteurs d'air
climatisé
l'objectif est en fait de définir un
cahier des charges perceptif c'est à
dire lorsque on doit installer un
convecteur d'art climatisés dans un
espace on doit savoir comment le sombre
à être perçue et est ce qu'il va être
gênant ou pas
[Musique]
donc à partir de cette cartographie pour
l'industriel pour le fabricant ça lui
donne en fait un ensemble de critères
perceptif à partir duquel il va définir
un cahier des charges et s'ils le
souhaitent
s'il veut créer un nouveau son et pourra
utiliser cette cartographie pour créer
ce nouveau le son qui va orienter en
fait sa création aura eu un travail avec
différents industriels en termes
d'interface homme-machine d'ordinateurs
pour traduire en fait des
fonctionnalités de l'ordinateur
par exemple ici on à l'indication de
l'ouverture d'une application selon une
typologie selon une autre typologie
selon une autre identité cela donnerait
sa l'arrivée d'un mail par exemple
[Musique]
l'envoi d'un mail selon une autre
typologie si tous les fabricants
investissait de la sorte dans la qualité
sonore de leur machine
nous pourrions enfin apprécier la bande
son de notre quotidien
c'est l'heure
donc ça veut dire que de trois heures en
voyant la sphère et le bassin carré ça
m'a semblé être comme une sorte de gros
mécanisme horloger en plus la sphère
rappelle l'univers appelle une notion de
temps de temporalité est alors pour un
musicien faire du temps sur le temps
c'est quand même un truc assez compliqué
et bien intéressant c'est une oeuvre
hybride parce que à la fois elle a un
pied dans la fonctionnalité il faut
quand même qu'on puisse arriver si on le
veut à savoir quelle heure il est en
plus de ça il faut une adaptation à un
milieu une adaptation au site donc en ce
sens on peut dire que c'est du design
sonore et puis d'un autre côté il ya une
création purement musical qui elle est
et lille
[Musique]
donc moi j'ai décidé à dire quand même
un peu arbitraire mans de créer une
musique par saison et de marquer
l'écoulement des secondes ça c'est ma
petite trotteuse qui tourne parce que il
faut quand même bien avoir du son mobile
ce qui est le plus intéressant à
travailler pour nous les minutes et les
heures
voilà avec ça on peut lire l'heure
plutôt écouter leurs et on peut
construire une vraie forme le design
sonore pour écouter le temps et surtout
pour se repérer dans l'espace à la cité
des sciences et de l'industrie à paris
il y aurait beaucoup à faire
alors ce qui est fait aujourd'hui pour
l'accessibilité au public qui a des
graves difficultés visuelles
c'est un dispositif de guidage au sol
qui permet une orientation assuré parce
que ici l'espace est immense et tous les
sons se mélangent et n'établissent pas
d'un véritable cadrage dans leur
réflexion sur les parois
non qu'on perçoit pas les limites et de
l'espace
ce qui serait bien sûr intéressant de
mettre en oeuvre dans ce grand
dispositif serait la capacité de gérer
d'une part architecturalement est aussi
techniquement la possibilité de
permettre à un public de passer dans des
zones sonore bien délimitées bien
établie
[Musique]
sur cette ligne ferroviaire parisienne
un projet unique en son genre pour une
fois architecte acousticien ont pensé à
notre confort visuel et sonore en même
temps la gamme magenta dans laquelle
nous sommes fait partie d'une famille de
bâtiments qui associe particulier d'être
souterrain donc forcément et de drainer
énormément de public énormément de
fluides public dont classe devient une
contrainte forte
du point de vue du confort et il faut
absolument traiter ce confort là et
minimiser disons le sentiment ou le
risque de sensation d'enfermement qu'on
peut avoir dans des espaces souterrains
comme cela on s'est dit que l'usager
devait parcourir sept gars là pour
atteindre sont en train en ayant un
parcours rythmé en fait par des espaces
très différenciée sur le plan sonore
ce partie sonore il démarre dans les
entrées de la gare les entrées qui sont
des couloirs de transit qui sont traités
de façon particulière dans ce sens qu
elles sont habillées de bois en totalité
habillé de bois et que sur le plan
sonore on a cherché à les rendre
extrêmement maths en maîtrisant la
réverbération la ressortir de ce sas
acoustique on débouche dans l'est dans
un rôle de façon systématique d'ailleurs
dans toutes les gares et hall les
bouches dans un rôle et l'idée c'était
de faire percevoir aux voyageurs une
transition sonore remarquable et là il
ya un fort contraste qui est tout à fait
perceptible entre l'acoustique feutré de
la l'entrée galerie de mine et
l'acoustique de ceux de cet espace qui
est beaucoup plus réverbérant qui est
traitée en béton essentiellement donc
c'est un béton glacée qui a la propriété
acoustique de réfléchir le son est
d'amplifier du coup l'ensemble des sons
qui sont présents on rentre dans un
espace qui est lui est beaucoup plus
confiné qui sur le plan sonore donc est
très contrastée par rapport
aux espaces précédent on a disposé en
voûte des gros coussins de mousse
absorbante
on a voulu favoriser notamment
l'ambiance générale pour favoriser la
lecture pour inciter aussi à la
discussion à voix basse cette perception
risque d'être inconsciente mais va
accentuer finalement l'impression la
sensation visuelle la perception de
l'espace ou simplement par cette
dimension sonore
le designer sonore qu'est-ce qui fait
c'est que il favorise cet échange verbal
un exemple une rue où le flux de bruit
n'est pas gérée va vous interdire la
communication entre vous et la ce moment
là je dis que il y à un danger si les
voitures étaient convenablement design
et si les urbanistes faisait bien leur
boulot pour gérer les flux de bruit etc
c'était raté terra donc tout ça mis bout
à bout ferait que au coeur de la ville
on aurait une bonne facilités dont 2
dont échange de communication
dans le domaine de l'aide pour les non
voyants
enfin on essaye de créer des choses
spécifiques pour une en voyant et en
fait on devrait réfléchir à créer des
choses qui servent à tout le monde et
pas besoin de parler aux gens pour leur
dire qu'il faut traverser que c'est le
moment de traverser ou que c'est pas le
moment de traverser vous trouver autre
chose
non seulement c'est ridicule ensuite
c'est se fiche des étrangers qui
viennent là et parce qu'ils vont rien
comprendre à ce signe alors comment on
ferait un sont finalement qui ce qui
pourrait être compris par tout le monde
c'est quand même une solution beaucoup
plus simple
heureusement certains secteurs comme les
transports publics font appel eux à des
spécialistes
il prend la suite du poinçonneur des
lilas il entre dans l'ère du sans
contact au départ c'était mort sur le
maintenant il n'y a plus rien plane au
dessus de la cible et ont déclenché un
feedback qui est lumineux et sonores le
but était que modifié le passage des
gens pour leur permettre de passer plus
vite lui qui est plus en plus de gens
qui prennent tous les matins le métro le
bus donc il ya un son qui est oui ok ou
loyal et vous êtes bienvenu vous êtes en
règle
vous êtes notre client vous aime bien
tout ça voilà on vous dit bonjour en
fait bien son qui est le nom de refus
absolu du genre non votre ticket n'est
pas valable
il est passé on veut pas de nous on est
désolé mais on doit vous refuser
l'entrée et puis il ya un troisième sion
qui est un vrai service en fait assez
assez nouveau qu' un sondage laërt qui
dit votre ticket est encore valable mais
plus pour très longtemps et il faut
penser à renouveler votre abonnement et
donc se sont déclenchés en trois mois et
deux semaines avant la fin de la
validité du ticket
on a travaillé comme toujours avec une
équipe de quatre personnes
un coordinateur c'est moi en
l'occurrence moi je suis acousticien
mais j'étais architecte avant donc je
suis venu à monde descend par l'espace
on va dire un compositeur une psycho
sociologue qui m'aident à interpréter ce
que vont ressentir les gens et puis un
technicien du son que je consulte
toujours dès que la technologie dépasse
un peu mes capacités
on a fait un sont excessifs simplicité
une note
et pas deux et pas une harmonie est pas
un accord vraiment une note
elle est un peu tenu un peu prolongé
d'une deuxième en dessous mais à peine
que ce soit pour le oui pour le nombre
le
wheelman 1 sont positifs ça monte un
sont négatifs ce à dessein et tout le
monde comprend un son aigu ça s'entend
un son grave - notre oreille est ainsi
fait
un sons très aigus passe infiniment
mieux parce que c'est la partie du
spectre où il ya peu d'événements
l'oiseau il est assez aisément
repérables dans l'arbre même si vous
vous promenez sur un boulevard très
bruyants les autocars ils peuvent pas
lutter contre un oiseau il passe le
l'oiseau orchestre c'est la même chose
dans un orchestre le triangle qui génère
une énergie quasi acoustique est très
faible
les trombones s'essouffle les
contrebasses yvon à plein marché et lui
fait d'un gain et le son stop y passe et
l'écologie dans tout ça cette voiture
électrique inventé par un constructeur
français aurait pu lui répondre
tu dis c'est un concept de voiture
urbaine électrique et il a été réalisé
dans les années 90 en fin de entre 90 et
la particularité de la voiture s'est
elle est toute petite elle a un design
très fort très particulier et la demande
qui est fait c'est il faut la doter d'un
son parce qu'une voiture électrique ça
fait pas de bruit c'est dangereux
là il ya deux types de réponses qu'on
peut faire un an fabrique un sont
artificielles quelconque on met quatre
haut parleurs et on en parle plus
deuxième solution faire en sorte que ce
soit l'objet lui même qui produisent
sont une voiture quand ça roule ça
génère du bruit bruit de friction
il ya des roues on peut utiliser les
plaques pénétration dans l'air on peut
utiliser l'air etc
il ya quantité de ressources entre
guillemets naturel donc essayer que ce
soit véritablement la voie de la voiture
et non pas un artifice qu'on va plaquer
sur la voiture
et ce beau travail de design sonore a
été abandonné par le constructeur
pourquoi
on cherche par rapport aux mots design
design sonore plus une fonction sonore
qui pourraient être ajoutés à certains
objets comme par exemple une chaise
sonore sur laquelle on s'assied et qui
en fonction de son poids pourrait faire
un son bien particulier
[Musique]
on a travaillé aussi sur des paillassons
pas un paillasson qui pourrait servir de
sonnette puisque considère que quand on
est poli on s'essuie les pieds pour
entrer chez les gens
les risques de dérives dans le design
sonore c'est plus à mon avis d'un point
de vue éthique du travail qu'on fait sur
les objets eux-mêmes
c'est par exemple je prends un exemple
simple un grille pain on pourrait très
bien un jour un industriel pourrait
venir nous voir en me disant voilà on
voudrait que vous le design et le son
d'un grille-pain futuriste quelque chose
de galactique
probablement si on n'arrive pas à le
convaincre d'autres choses on refuserait
de faire l'étude parce que pour nous le
grille pain est un objet qui existent au
niveau sont tels qu'il est il est bien
il n'est pas agressif il a et véhicules
beaucoup de souvenirs de il a une vraie
valeur sonore je pense qu'en fait on
pour lui proposerait d'enregistrer deux
manières par contre exceptionnel un bon
mais on changerait pas radicalement le
ce sont là parce qu'il existe une
véhicule une fonction vraiment
clairement et quand le design sonore
rencontre l'art
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
le son a une importance mais c'est tout
à fait à dépendre dans de nous nous le
savons nous sommes constitués ainsi nous
produisons du bruit je bouge j'ai des
activités elles sont productrices de
prix bref la vie fait nécessairement du
bruit on ne sortira pas de là on a un
rôle important d'éducation des enfants
par rapport son par rapport au bruit et
j'espère que eux sauront dire non sort
ont lutté seront en tant que
consommateur refusé le n'importe quoi
sonore c'est sûr j'en suis convaincu que
peut-être dans cinq dix quinze ans on
pourra on pourra pas sortir un objet un
produit manufacturé sans qu'il y ait une
réflexion sur le son de cet objet ont
souvent inclus mais ça va mettre
probablement du temps
d'abord entendu comme un bruit
comment tu t'appelles entendu comme un
bruit
comment
on
[Musique]